Est-ce que vous connaissez
Vasyl Lomachenko ?
C’est un boxeur ukrainien,
encore en activité.
Et c’est le boxeur
LE PLUS TECHNIQUE
qui ait jamais existé.
Il est si rapide,
et si précis,
que ses adversaires,
qui sont pourtant
les MEILLEURS
boxeurs au monde
— ses adversaires abandonnent
DE DÉCOURAGEMENT !
Et voici comment Lomachenko
explique son succès :
« Un boxeur gagne,
un boxeur perd ;
c’est simplement que
l’un est mieux préparé,
l’autre moins bien préparé.
»
Donc si Lomachenko
CARTONNE
sur le ring,
c’est parce qu’il se prépare
TRÈS SÉRIEUSEMENT,
et TRÈS SPÉCIFIQUEMENT.
Il ne fait pas les choses au hasard,
il suit une stratégie.
Vous voulez CARTONNER
en dissertation aux concours ?
Vous avez besoin
de la bonne STRATÉGIE.
Ça fait UNE DIZAINE D’ANNÉES
que je prépare des candidats
aux épreuves de dissertation
des concours les plus difficiles
— HEC,
Polytechnique,
les concours administratifs,
les concours
de la fonction publique,
etc. —
et je remarque toujours
la même chose :
vous ne savez pas
où vous allez !
Pour la plupart,
vous vous dites
que vous allez réviser le cours,
faire les DS prévus
au cours de l’année,
et puis vous espérez
que ça va marcher !
Mais non,
ça ne va pas marcher !
Si vous faites LA MÊME CHOSE
que tous les candidats,
vous aurez LES MÊMES RÉSULTATS
que tous les candidats !
Donc si vous voulez CARTONNER,
vous avez besoin d’une stratégie
POUR CARTONNER.
Eh bien je vais vous révéler
LES TROIS CLÉS
de cette stratégie
dans cette vidéo.
Une petite précision
avant de commencer :
je ne vais pas vous dire
les choses évidentes
que vous connaissez déjà,
parce que je ne veux pas
vous faire perdre votre temps
— je sais
que vous avez beaucoup de travail.
Par exemple,
vous devez bien sûr
TRÈS BIEN connaître
les modalités
de votre épreuve de dissertation,
le programme de la matière,
etc.
— ça ne servira à rien
que je vous en parle.
Non,
je vais vous donner
des techniques de préparation
auxquelles vous n’avez PAS pensé.
Regardez donc attentivement cette vidéo
jusqu’au bout,
et vous ferez partie
de la minorité des candidats
de votre concours
qui SAVENT
comment se préparer
pour CARTONNER
en dissertation.
« De même qu’un excès de nourriture
gâte l’estomac et nuit à l’organisme
tout entier,
on peut aussi,
par un excès de nourriture intellectuelle,
surcharger et étouffer l’esprit.
»
Schopenhauer
La PREMIÈRE clé
pour cartonner en dissertation
à vos concours,
c’est de préparer
un STOCK
de connaissances.
Pourquoi est-ce que c’est
SI important ?
Eh bien,
parce que votre problème,
c’est l’EXCÈS
d’information.
Il y a TROP de choses
que vous devez savoir.
À quoi bon
avoir un cours de
PLUSIEURS CENTAINES
de pages?
Ça prend un temps FOU à réviser ;
vous ne retiendrez jamais tout ;
et vous ne maîtriserez pas
ce que vous retiendrez
— c’est-à-dire que vous aurez du mal
à MOBILISER
vos connaissances
en dissertation.
C’est comme
lorsque vous faites les courses :
vous n’achetez pas
dix kilos de bananes d’un coup,
parce que vous n’avez pas besoin
d’autant de bananes
— et si vous pensez finir les dix kilos
au bout de plusieurs mois,
vous ne pourrez pas,
parce que les bananes vont pourrir !
En pratique,
vous savez donc à peu près
de quelle quantité de bananes
vous avez besoin
pour la semaine à venir.
Eh bien pour la dissertation,
c’est pareil :
vous n’avez PAS BESOIN
de centaines de pages de cours !
Vous devez donc ESTIMER
la quantité de savoir nécessaire
pour être en mesure
de réussir vos épreuves de dissertation.
Et ça,
ça n’est pas très difficile.
Vous devez simplement
vous poser les bonnes questions :
de combien de connaissances,
ou de références,
avez-vous besoin
dans une dissertation ?
Par exemple,
dans une dissertation
de trois fois trois parties,
on a besoin de dix références :
une pour l’accroche,
et une pour chaque paragraphe
du développement.
Autre question
que vous devez vous poser :
votre stock de connaissances,
ça doit faire combien de pages
à peu près ?
S’il est trop gros,
ça prendra trop de temps
à réviser ;
et s’il est trop court,
vous serez peut-être à sec
pour traiter certains sujets.
Alors,
ça dépend bien sûr
de la taille de la police
et d’autres facteurs de mise en forme,
mais au doigt mouillé,
je pense
que vous ne devriez pas dépasser
CENT PAGES.
Autres exemples de questions
que vous devez vous poser :
quelle est L’AMPLEUR
de votre programme ?
Quelle quantité de connaissances
est-ce que vous devez sélectionner
PAR THÈME
pour être à l’aise
lors de votre épreuve ?
Par exemple,
si vous préparez
une dissertation d’économie,
combien de théories,
de statistiques,
et d’exemples historiques
est-ce que vous avez intérêt
À RETENIR
pour chaque chapitre
de votre programme ?
Vous ne pouvez pas TOUT retenir !
Soyez donc très PRAGMATIQUES :
regardez précisément
votre programme ;
identifiez les types de connaissances
dont vous avez besoin ;
pensez au TEMPS
que vous allez devoir investir
pour CRÉER votre stock de connaissances
mais aussi,
ensuite,
pour l’APPRENDRE,
et soyez réalistes :
nous surestimons toujours nos besoins,
et il n’y a que vingt-quatre heures
dans une journée.
Je ne peux pas vous donner
des indications plus précises,
parce qu’il y a beaucoup de concours différents
et d’épreuves de dissertation différentes.
DONC si vous voulez des indications
plus précises,
posez-moi vos questions
dans les commentaires,
et je vous répondrai avec plaisir.
Maintenant,
une fois que vous avez estimé
la quantité de savoir nécessaire
pour réussir votre épreuve,
vous devez le FORMATER
en vue de l’exercice de la dissertation.
Vous devez rendre vos connaissances
FACILES à utiliser
en dissertation.
Et pour ça,
vous devez faire trois choses.
Tout d’abord,
CLARIFIER les connaissances,
parce que si vous ne les comprenez pas,
vous ne pourrez pas
les mobiliser EFFICACEMENT
en dissertation.
Et puis c’est cette première nécessité,
la clarification,
qui rend possible la deuxième.
La deuxième chose que vous devez faire
pour formater les connaissances
en vue de la dissertation,
c’est de LES RELIER
à des idées ESSENTIELLES
des thèmes du programme.
Pourquoi est-ce que
vous devez faire ça ?
Pour commencer
D’ORES ET DÉJÀ
à réfléchir dans la perspective
de l’argumentation.
Pour le dire plus simplement,
à chaque fois vous voyez une connaissance
que vous pourriez ajouter à votre stock,
vous vous dites :
« Ça pourrait me servir
à montrer ça,
ou bien à montrer ça.
»
C’est-à-dire que vous essayez
D'ANTICIPER
les arguments auxquels vous pourrez
apporter du CRÉDIT
grâce à la connaissance
en question.
En fait,
vous vous demandez
si la connaissance sera RENTABLE
— et ça,
c’est important,
parce que vous ne créez pas
un stock de connaissances
pour vous faire plaisir,
ou pour améliorer votre culture générale,
mais pour RÉUSSIR
vos épreuves de dissertation.
Le savoir que vous préparez
devra être UTILE !
Je vais vous donner quelques exemples.
Si vous mettez dans votre stock
la théorie des Idées de Platon,
vous pouvez anticiper que cette théorie
vous servira à apporter du crédit
à l’idée selon laquelle
la vérité n’est pas dans l’apparence,
ou bien
à l’idée selon laquelle
le philosophe doit parvenir
à la vraie connaissance.
Je vous donne un autre exemple
Si,
en économie,
vous notez dans votre stock de connaissances
la théorie du multiplicateur de Keynes,
vous pouvez anticiper que cette théorie
vous servira à apporter du crédit
à l’idée selon laquelle
l’État peut intervenir efficacement
dans l’économie,
ou bien
à l’idée selon laquelle
l’État peut soutenir la demande
SANS alourdir la fiscalité.
Allez,
un dernier petit exemple.
Si vous notez le Rapport Grégoire
de 1794
— c’était un rapport
sur l’universalisation
de la langue française —
eh bien si vous notez ce rapport
dans votre stock de connaissances,
vous pouvez anticiper qu’il
vous servira à apporter du crédit
à l’idée selon laquelle
la France n’était pas unie
à l’époque de la Révolution,
ou bien
à l’idée selon laquelle
la France actuelle
est en partie le produit
de L’ÉTAT français.
Voilà pour les exemples.
Souvenez-vous que
lorsque vous choisissez une référence,
vous devez anticiper les arguments de dissertation
qu’elle vous servira à crédibiliser.
Enfin,
la troisième et dernière chose
que vous devez faire
pour FORMATER
les connaissances que vous stockez,
c’est de préparer l’explication
que vous devrez fournir
pour développer chaque connaissance.
Vous vous souvenez que
lorsque vous introduisez
une connaissance en dissertation,
vous devez ensuite l’expliquer
en quelques phrases.
Alors,
bien sûr,
il faut être capable de le faire
— donc vous ne devez pas apprendre
les connaissances dont vous vous servirez
en mode NAME DROPPING —
MAIS vous ne devez pas NON PLUS
lire un bouquin EN ENTIER
pour maîtriser la connaissance !
Ce n’est pas du tout rentable !
Vous devez simplement être capable
de parler de la connaissance que vous mobilisez
en quelques phrases.
DONC lorsque vous prenez des notes,
en pratique,
quelques bullet points
SUFFISENT.
Voilà,
en résumé,
pour formater les connaissances
en vue de la dissertation,
clarifiez-les ;
anticipez les arguments
qu’elles serviront à crédibiliser ;
et ne perdez pas trop de temps
sur chaque référence
— limitez votre capacité d’explication.
Vous connaissez maintenant
les deux PRINCIPES CRUCIAUX
pour préparer un stock de connaissances :
QUANTIFIER le savoir nécessaire,
et FORMATER ce savoir.
Après,
vous devez bien sûr TROUVER
les connaissances,
— mais ça,
ce n’est pas difficile :
vous avez des cours et des manuels,
donc vous n’avez pas besoin de mes conseils.
Et enfin,
vous devrez STOCKER
les connaissances :
je pense que vous savez
écrire sur un ordinateur,
donc pour ça aussi,
vous n’avez pas besoin de mes conseils.
Allez,
je passe à la deuxième clé
pour cartonner en dissertation
aux concours.
« On ne peut se passer d’une méthode.
»
Descartes
La deuxième clé de la réussite en dissertation
aux concours,
c’est la MÉTHODOLOGIE.
La dissertation est un exercice COMPLEXE,
donc si vous y allez à l’arrache,
ça va être la catastrophe.
C’est L’INVERSE
que vous devez faire :
vous ne devez RIEN
laisser au hasard ;
vous devez PRÉCISÉMENT savoir
ce que vous devez faire
tout au long de l’épreuve ;
vous suivez un mode opératoire,
des consignes ;
vous appliquez des techniques
que vous maîtrisez.
Alors,
je ne vais pas vous dire
tout ce qu’il faut faire
dans cette vidéo,
parce que j’en aurais pour des heures.
Non,
j’ai une solution plus simple pour vous
:
inscrivez-vous
à mon cours GRATUIT
de méthodologie.
Le lien doit s’afficher maintenant
en haut à droite,
et vous pouvez aussi le trouver
dans la description de la vidéo.
C’est un cours par e-mail,
donc vous pouvez d’abord regarder cette
vidéo,
et puis vous lirez mon cours après,
ou dans les prochains jours.
Voilà,
donc c’est bon
pour les deux premières clés :
je vous ai parlé de la préparation
de votre stock de connaissances,
et en vous inscrivant à mon cours par e-mail,
vous aurez une méthodologie SOLIDE.
MAIS…
ce n’est pas encore suffisant
pour CARTONNER
en dissertation aux concours.
« Plus je m’entraîne
et plus j’ai de la chance.
»
Arnold Palmer
La TROISIÈME clé
pour cartonner en dissertation
aux concours,
c’est de S’ENTRAÎNER.
Alors,
j’imagine votre réaction :
« Oh mais c’est évident !
On le savait déjà ! »
Oui,
peut-être que vous le savez.
MAIS est-ce que
vous le FAITES ?!
Non,
j’en suis certain :
si vous regardez cette vidéo,
c’est que
vous vous entraînez MAL.
Alors,
comment s’entraîner
pour CARTONNER
aux concours ?
Il y a
TROIS DIMENSIONS importantes.
Première dimension :
vous devez vous entraîner
EN CONDITIONS RÉELLES.
Si vous voulez devenir bon
au cent mètres,
vous n’allez pas vous contenter
de faire des footings ;
vous n’allez pas passer tout votre temps
à la salle de musculation ;
non,
vous allez faire
DES CENT MÈTRES
ET ENCORE
des cent mètres.
Le principe qu’il y a derrière,
c’est que dans l’entraînement,
il faut SIMULER
le plus possible
l’exercice à réussir.
Donc ne vous contentez pas
d’apprendre votre cours ;
faites UN MAXIMUM
de plans détaillés,
rédigez UN MAXIMUM
de dissertations.
SIMULEZ le plus possible
TOUTES les opérations
que vous aurez à exécuter le jour J,
aux concours.
La DEUXIÈME DIMENSION
d’un bon entraînement,
c’est la RÉGULARITÉ.
Il y a des élèves qui me disent :
« Romain,
j’ai lu ton cours de méthodo
et j’ai appliqué tes conseils,
mais ça n’a pas marché ! »
Alors moi,
je leur demande :
« T’as fait combien de plans détaillés
et de dissertations
pendant l’année ?
Tu peux me les montrer ? »
Et ils me répondent
toujours la même chose :
« Je n’avais pas le temps,
je devais apprendre le cours ! »
Vous aurez beau avoir
l’entraîneur de Rafael Nadal,
si vous ne tapez pas dans la balle
TOUS LES JOURS,
vous ne progresserez pas
et vous perdrez les matchs.
C’est pareil en dissertation :
vous avez besoin d’un VOLUME MINIMUM
d’entraînement.
Alors,
vous n’avez pas besoin
de travailler autant
que Nadal au tennis,
mais vous devez vous entraîner
RÉGULIÈREMENT.
Par exemple,
vous pouvez faire
UN PLAN DÉTAILLÉ
par semaine
— c’est l’histoire d’une heure,
une heure et demi,
et à la fin de l’année,
vous en aurez traité
des sujets !
Soyez donc RÉGULIERS ;
ne travaillez pas par à-coups :
ça ne marche pas.
Si vous travaillez par à-coups,
votre compétence intellectuelle
SE DÉGRADERA
dans les périodes
où vous ne vous entraînerez pas,
si bien que
lorsque vous vous remettrez à travailler,
vous repartirez à zéro.
En fait,
la compétence intellectuelle,
c’est comme en musculation :
sans entraînement,
le muscle fond,
et vous avez besoin DE TEMPS
pour progresser.
Je le répète donc :
entraînez-vous
RÉ-GU-LIÈ-RE-MENT.
Travaillez un peu
de temps en temps.
TROISIÈME DIMENSION
pour bien vous entraîner :
le FEEDBACK.
Lorsqu’un coureur
fait un cent mètres,
il a un chronomètre
qui lui permet d’évaluer sa performance.
Vous c’est pareil :
vous devez faire évaluer
votre travail,
pour savoir ce que vous avez raté,
et ce que vous avez réussi.
Comment faire ?
Eh bien,
vous pouvez déjà
demander à vos amis
— ils ne sont peut-être
pas très forts en dissertation,
mais c’est toujours mieux que rien.
Vous pouvez aussi demander
à vos profs
— en général,
ils sont d’accord.
MAIS si vous voulez
vous entraîner SÉRIEUSEMENT,
vous faire corriger SYSTÉMATIQUEMENT,
et DANS LE DÉTAIL,
eh bien vous pouvez vous inscrire
à ma formation AVANCÉE
à la méthodologie de la dissertation,
parce que je corrige TOUT
ce que m’envoient mes élèves,
sans aucune limite
— au contraire,
moi je les encourage
à m’envoyer plus de plans détaillés,
plus de dissertations,
parce que je sais que s’ils le font,
alors ILS CARTONNERONT
aux concours.
En résumé,
il y a trois clés pour CARTONNER
en dissertation aux concours :
préparer un stock de connaissances
OPTIMISÉ,
en volume et en format,
pour VOTRE ÉPREUVE
de dissertation ;
ensuite,
maîtriser une méthodologie SOLIDE ;
et enfin,
s’entraîner
LE PLUS SÉRIEUSEMENT possible.
Je vous garantis
que si vous vous concentrez
SUR CES TROIS CLÉS,
vous allez CARTONNER
aux concours.
Vous avez des questions,
ou des remarques ?
Écrivez-moi dans les commentaires.
J’espère que cette vidéo vous a plu
et qu’elle vous sera utile.
Je suis Romain,
je suis toujours avec mon fidèle Haristote,
et vous étiez
sur 1000 idées de culture générale.
Rappelez-vous
que vous n’avez pas besoin
de vous prendre la tête
pour CARTONNER
en dissertation.